you know I think what makes Cola
interesting as to an investor or to
anyone is really two things it's been
able to you know maintain its point of
view as a brand over time and this is
what is commonly referred to as an
iconic brand so in other words there are
great brands out there lots of brands
but there are relatively few that is are
able to maintain a point of view on the
changing times around them so if you
think about it coke has always had a
point of view on society so in the early
60s when there's a lot of cultural
change you know that a point of view on
race relationships and remember that the
Mean Joe green commercial where me and
Joe green tosses shirt to the kid this
is what makes brands iconic having a
point of view around the world around
them and then the second thing is I
think coke has always been able to
leverage its assets in new ways of
course we have a core business but it's
always been able to adapt and change to
the marketplace by offering new products
and services again that are outside of
our core business I mean coke and every
other large corporation can't remain
can't stand on its laurels right so you
have to adapt every large company or
brand or product must adapt to be
relevant every company is right now
afraid of having a Kodak moment you can
imagine the people inside of Kodak
looking at the iPhone and calling it a
toy at some point now they're not you
know so that's what every large company
every brand you know should be looking
at and frankly avoiding and lots of
phrases out there right now rolling
around disruptive innovation and so
forth but whatever you what do you want
to call it every brand every company
every large organization must remain
relevant or they simply die
you